[Music]
the jars are kindly folk
[Music]
brought to life by human flesh and blood
which can be stored safely within
we can't be sure why they were created
however the urge tree is imprinted upon
their wax seals
and there are empty jars at the bases of
many minor oak trees
perhaps they once transported bodies
here for burial
[Music]
at any rate their purpose has long been
lost
since the shattering
and now they live in fear
for there are those who would pay a high
price
for the shard of a living jar
one's choice of armor says a lot about
them
maybe it's the armor of a nameless
vagabond
or the armor of one to whom family is
everything
for dialos this armor was passed down to
him
and many expectations came with it
ah hello
he must be new here
i'm well just call me dialos
the honor of one's house holds little
import in these lands
by the way
have you met a young woman named lanya
on your travels she's my servant
but fickle is the wind take your eyes
off her for but a moment and she's good
as gone
if you find her
please be sure to tell me
[Music]
melania
it's me dialos
answer me would you
[Music]
hello friend tell me if you know would
you the whereabouts of the hidden house
of those despicable fiends the recusants
who hunt their fellow tarnished
they laid hands upon my servant lanyard
and i refuse to let the insult stand
the tale of house hoslow is told in
blood
i dialos
swear to deliver the message
lania was a tarnished servant of house
hoslow
and a companion of dialos since
childhood
so she might have known better than
anyone that dialos was all talk
and no action
the recusants are tarnished who have
turned their backs on grace and the odd
tree
such blasphemy leads them to hunt fellow
tarnished to foil the efforts of those
guided by grace
this recusant's name is henriques a
night killer who would have crushed
dialos
but he makes the mistake of invading you
[Music]
hello
can you hear me
help me i'm stuck hello
hello
oh my stars i'm so happy to see you
and as you can see i'm stuck here
please
can you help me out of this
my thanks a thousand thanks
just give me a good smack from the rear
with something nice and big
and i'll pop clean out i'm sure
don't dally
no there's no need to fret i'm very well
trained
give it your all i say
ouch
a little more gently yeah
well played good sir well played
i
thank you
once again the pleasure is mine
i am the warrior jar known as alexander
iron fist alexander in fact
i journey to the east
where i intend to further my education
in the ways of war
and beyond these lands lie the scarlet
rot blighted kailid wilds
and upon their southern edge is red main
castle
in which a festival of combat is being
held
i'd heard whispers of such festivities
before
doesn't the notion set your breast of
flutter
[Music]
ah
you came how delightful
indeed i thought i might find you here
by the by do you know for whom this
festival is being held
well
it is none other than general radan
himself
to think
i could face a great champion of the
shattering
a demigod in the flesh
in truth i quiver at the thought
such is his frightful repute but
the fear simply assures me the ordeal is
worth undertaking
be sure to get a good vantage my friend
i
iron fist alexander do hereby vow to
unflinchingly brave this ordeal
[Music]
general
is cursed over to wander
eaten from the inside by melania's
scarlet rod
[Music]
but his great rune burns to resist the
encroachment of the rot
and while he is long since mad
he was once the strongest of the
demigods
and perhaps the greatest warrior of all
[Music]
[Music]
but in the end you are the host to this
warrior's death
and those beside you are simply summoned
to share in your glory
ah hello there
um
it was a battle marvelously fought
you are well and truly a champion friend
i on the other hand
have nothing but a croc
one hit was all it took to crack me and
for my insides to come spilling out
after that i
my
head like a coward
and as such
i can hardly stand to face one such as
you
the bodies found here are exceedingly
fine
who could expect any less from the very
warriors who fought in the shattering
the greatest of all wars
all right lads
i'm going to take you on a little
journey
you'll all be inside me
from now on
we're all in it together
thus our warriors passed from jar to
john
carrying dreams of greatness
ah
you again is it
the recusant center lucky
can you believe they invited me to join
them now after what they did i can
scarcely believe it myself
do they think be a fool
you might be surprised to learner took
them up on the offer then they only had
to ask
the location of the recusant hideout
it's on mount gelmir found off the old
road that leads west from the town of
windmills that's where they hide
the manor on the peak
just you wait wretched recusants
you'll rue the day you insulted my name
by laying hands on lanyard
the tale of house oslo is told in blood
after all
dialos had an older brother
a stern self-possessed man named juno
who inherited the hoslow legacy instead
of dialis
true to the words of his house juno
hoslow walked many roads drenched in
blood
yet never had the ego to consider
himself a champion
but the casual manner of his
achievements made him seem out of reach
and so the younger aspired to be like
the older
yearning for the day that he would tell
the tale of house hoslo in blood
knowing full well that it would break
his brother's heart
help me i'm stuck hello
[Music]
my thanks in advance
i know you're the man for the job
you know what to do hmm
ah
ouch
what if i could somehow be made slippery
or some such
god
oh
nearly me
i'm oilier than a toad
my thanks
yes indeed
i too have a home
though it is one to which i have vowed
not to return
so
i thought i might look out from atop the
cliff
but as i drew closer and closer
pow
wouldn't you know it
i was perfectly stuck in that blasted
hole
i can feel the warriors inside
admonishing me for my morkishness
and so we learn that just over the cliff
is jarburg a hidden little village where
the jars can live in peace
hello coz
what are you doing here
i didn't think anyone knew about this
place
except us jars
ah
are you going to be the new potentate
show me your hands
it's just a little test cuz
to see if you've got the right stuff
hmm
your skin
isn't so smooth
is it
you need slick slidy hands to be
potentate you know
i'm sorry cuz
but i don't think you've got what it
takes
what's a shame
a potentate is a leader of the jars who
in this case it seems is judged worthy
by the quality of their hands
hands grow rough and calloused by war
but most living jars are kindly and
would not value such a ruler better
instead to have a potentate who can take
care of them
though this jah ban secretly has the
insides of a warrior so he desires a
protector to look up to
do you know what a poacher is cuz
they hunt us
smash us
and then take us away
this village is kept secret
so
i think we're safe here
but you should be careful if you ever
meet one of them cause
i hope uncle alexander beat small up
first
living jar shards are in high demand
in fact their shards are a crafting
material used by the most depraved
perfumers who grow desperate to craft
their potions and explosives as such the
perfumers must never be allowed to find
their way to jarburg
if you met uncle alexander
he used to live here with us but then he
left to be a champion one day
i'll be just like uncle alexander
i miss him though
i asked to go with him but he said oh
mountain of fire
make me in your flames
ah good sir
what business might you have in such a
place is this
it's hardly more than lukewarm here
i won't be able to temper my body such
that it'll never crack again
perhaps i'll head eastward
there's an old saying i've caught wind
of
above the lofty clouds the icy giant's
peak doth soar
here lieth the flame of ruin whichever
burning roars
[Music]
your
timing though is impeccable as ever
i've been making just the thing for you
on my journey here
take it
i'm sure it'll suit you to a team
[Music]
eventually you find your way to the
volcano manor
home of the recusants
am tanith
the proprietors of this house
an honor
to have you
so
tarnished
have you ever harboured doubts
about the burden of grace and the
dogmatic ramblings of the fingers
if you have
why not join the volcano manor
and fight with us
rise with us
against the earth tree tanith calls for
champions to join her cause and she
speaks well to the ambitions of the
tarnished
such validation was impossible for
dialos to resist
well nice to see you again
so you've been invited as well i see
then we're comrades in arms henceforth
you watch my back and i'll watch yours
yes
i um
i can tell
you're wondering about lanyard well you
see i
after much internal debate i've come to
realize
revenge is not the answer
according to lady tanith
i've got the stuff of champions
and champions ironic as it is are oft
forced to walk a tainted path
it hit me like a bolt from the blue
that my former thoughts were simple
naivety
of course my heart weeps for lania
that unfortunate incident was a cruel
twist of fate indeed but succumbing to
the pain and sadness caused won't make
me a champion will it
lanya knows this i'm certain
fate has laid hard roads for us both
but such is true of any road trod by
champions
i always resented these hands
their pale complexion
a far cry from any warriors
the shame of house oslo but that won't
be the case for long they'll be darkened
by grit once i've set out on the path of
champions
the tale of house hoslow is told in
blood after all
did you read the letter left for
you that is the task the volcano manor
desires you enact
you will be compensated once the deed is
done
good luck
if you are loathed to hunt your own kin
so be it but you must leave this house
at once
[Music]
this is a war against the earth tree
we have no place for the meek
nor the luxury of keeping clean hands
and so
we come face to face with juno hoslow
[Music]
then we are comrades in arms henceforth
you watch my back and i'll watch yours
yes
[Music]
when juno hoslow received an invitation
to the volcano manor he discreetly
refused
as head of house hoslow his hands had
been bloodied enough already
what's the matter having trouble nabbing
your prey
do you remember your vow to taneth
to rise against the earth tree
here i say your heart was never in it to
begin with
you and dialos both
well aren't you full of beans no wonder
you're covered in muck
oh
my friend it's been far too long i have
to say you caught me at a rather low
point but as you see
i've put all that behind me left a
volcano manor forging my own path now
making my own choices
even a fool like me can look after some
simple jars do you pity me
well don't
i feel like for the first time in my
life
i'm on the straight and narrow
when dialys hoslo finally set aside the
expectations of others
he started to listen to himself
oh hello again cuz
have you heard
a new potentate's come to the village
i think he said his name was
dialos
he seems a little down in the dumps but
his hands
as smooth as silk
i don't know
i'm a little disappointed actually
even though good sir dialos has a
wonderful suit of armor
he says he isn't a warrior
and since he's a coward
he won't be fighting anymore
his smooth and silky hands feel nice
when he pats us
but i wish we had a potentate big and
strong like you
which brings us to the perfumers who
have had reason to follow you here the
perfumers were once respected healers
who traveled the land in search of
flower fields and aromatics so that they
might better treat the less fortunate
but after they were drafted onto the
battlefields of the shattering they were
forced to trade their pleasant aromatics
for consumable tools of war
so in jarburg they don't see the rare
flowers
or the peaceful jars
they see a village of crafting materials
ruled by a coward
wait
you're reporter aren't you i'll turn my
back on duty no more the tale of house
oslo is told in blood
in blood
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
for years dialys had yearned to tell the
tale of house hoslow in blood
all it took
was something worth fighting for
meanwhile you and alexander make your
way to the mountaintops of the giants
continuing upon the path of champions
[Music]
[Music]
ah i see you finally made it here
yourself
the city hanging in the air is slowly
crumbling
what an incredible place we find
ourselves
but that aside
you're certainly a force to be reckoned
with eh
which means i've but one thing to ask of
you
i've been longing to fight a warrior's
accomplished as you
you are ready then i take it
then let us begin
i am the great jar warrior
iron fist alexander
lend me strength o warriors within
let us become one champion together
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
as i suspected
victory
was impossible
my thanks
it was a marvelous battle
i implore you take what i bequeath
from inside me
all vessels are destined to one day
break
but the great alexander
lived as a warrior to his last
unlike dialys alexander was brave and
threw himself into danger at every turn
but in the end
his armor was not enough
for the warrior within
oh
because
i'm glad you came
but we're fine now
dialos fought the poacher
though quite a lot of us got broken
[Music]
i won't cry though
i'm a warrior jar
a warrior
the tale of house hoslow is told in
blood
that's the kind of warrior i want to be
one day cause
even if i'm scared
i'll still fight to protect
everyone
ah
you
are the jars
are they all right
[Music]
did i defend them
then all is well
this fool proved his worth
in the end
and so it is that the coward is capable
of the highest heroism
wow
cuz
are these
insights
from uncle alexander
thank you cuz
i'm a warrior jar
so i need to be strong
i can really have them
right
i understand
i'll get strong
strong enough
i deserve to have uncle's insights
i don't think i'll see you again when i
set out
warriors are supposed to work alone
goodbye
cause
and thanks for everything
i'll never forget you
[Music]
because jars contain drakes inherited
from those who came before
thus our warriors passed from jah to jah
carrying dreams
of greatness
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without the help of miss pap one a new
creator on the scene who has a lot of
cinematic talent go and check out his
channel for more cinematic footage like
this he also plans to make little
epilogues for these prepare to cry
episodes that we do together which i'm
very excited to see but working together
you know both of us could create
something that was better than either of
us working alone
and that's what i've learned from
working with other people in the last
few years we are more than the sum of
our parts and i think that's a good
metaphor for this video especially
on that note i want to start building a
bigger team so that i can make better
videos faster as well
this was something i meant to do before
eldon ring launched but i just didn't
have the time so if you're deeply
knowledgeable about any aspect of from
software's games and you would like to
have a paid role like this then send an
email to the next potentate gmail.com
specifically i'm looking for writers
mostly at this stage so if you have any
examples of your written work that
you've done in the past that would
really help to put you at the top of the
list but if you have any other skills or
knowledge like in editing animation or
anything really then that could be
welcome as well just a heads up i might
not be able to respond to everyone but
thank you if you do submit something if
i can put out better videos faster and
make a real effort to still retain what
makes them unique to me and also help
other people make a living from these
games then i think that would be really
cool i've definitely been feeling
pressure with the release of eldon ring
to put it mildly but there's just so
much that i want to make for you guys
but i feel like i never have the time
but regardless thank you for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you